وكان شو تريتاير وولد اسمه
طبعا هذا الشيء يبنى على التوزيع الجغرافي
المحتاجين في التنوع اللي راح يكون فيه
العمر اللي احنا راح نركز عليه مثلا بطوله
كاس العالم لازم 18 سنه وما فوق والاحتياج
وطبيعه الاحتياج
شايفين حقيقي
مختلفه اسقاط العالم
للعمل مجانا في هذا المونديال ما الذي
يمثله بالنسبه لكم البطوله عربيه
بطوله تستطيع انها ايضا تبني جسور
المتعارف ما بين شعوب العالم وكان تقطع
اساسيه بالنسبه لنا
من اول يوم قدمنا في الملف كان مؤمنين قوه
كره القدم وكاس العالم بشكل عام على نهايه
استطيع ان يتقرب ما بين الشعوب انا في
وجهه نظري نجاح اي بطوله احد العناصر
الاساسيه والرئيسيه هم المتطوعين
[موسيقى]
انا بقول احنا يعني بالنسبه للعالم احنا
اكثر من الف ليله وليلهنا احنا اكثر من
الصوره انا معطيه اللي موجوده احنا وطن
عربي احنا الشعب عربي
فيه كم من المواهب وفي كم من من الفخر
والثقه وكمل الغزار الثقافيه اللي موجوده
اللي راح نظهر فيها العالم راح تنبهروا
فيها
الجغرافيا
اين قطر كما ان احد اكثر الاسئله التي دمر
يتم سؤالي عنها في بلدي هو هل يفرض علي
لبس الحجاب وفي الطبع الجواب لا والكثير
من مثل هذا النمط من الاسئله خلال التجربه
التطوعي تعلمته الكثيره عن هذه المنطقه
كما تعلمت كيفيه التعامل مع اشخاص مختلفين
من دول المختلفه ومن ثقافات وهذا كان احد
اهداف من وراء التطوع حيث انني تعلمت منهم
الكثير كما ان المشاركه معه ثقافه الكذب
تاريخيه
همم رح تكون الاولى في حياتهم وباذن الله
لن تكون لاخره مرحبا بكم مرحبا بكم في هذا
العالم العربي الرائع حبيبوني
[موسيقى]